in hawaii right now
the government is using
robot dogs
to patrol homeless camps
and
and scan their heads
and make sure that none of them have a
fever and if they are they will
intervene
as part of the
covid
public health tyranny that is like
terminator stuff that is like robocop
stuff that is stuff that i did not know
existed in reality and apparently
it does these robot dogs
are equipped with cameras
two-way communication artificial
intelligence
autonomous data collection capabilities
and scanners that scan your eyes to
detect for fevers
then they interview people who have the
fevers and test positive
this is very spooky and it's very
inhumane
one we shouldn't be tolerating homeless
camps
we are tolerating them increasingly
around new york around austin around
los angeles and all these places
but that is in human and in
humane
all right two we shouldn't just be
interacting with people through robots
james pulas over at the claremont
institute he has this idea that
transgenderism the crazy transgender
focus right now is actually just a foot
into
transhumanism
that it's
it's about transcending our humanity
uploading everything to the cloud this
is this is wrong this is the sort of
thing it might be more efficient
you know we've had this debate on the
right for a long time it might be more
efficient it might increase gdp it might
make markets work better but it's just
inhuman i
here's my bold claim i don't want to
live in a country run by robot dogs okay
speaking of robots gotta get to this
clip i've been putting it off for a few
days
i'm not sure that joe biden is a human
because he hear me out he was on cnn
just talking to anderson cooper
he looked
he looked like a robot he didn't know
what to do with his hands take a listen
just in terms of inflation because you
had told uh us at the town hall i think
it was in july
that the in this it was just near-term
inflation
so joe biden just standing there got his
hands up he doesn't it's like it's like
that scene in 30 rock where alec baldwin
i don't know what to do with my hands
joe biden doesn't know what to do with
his hands
joe biden is obviously not all
there
okay
but
the scarier part is not just that we
have a guy who's doesn't have a whole
lot going on between the years running
the country the scary part is the people
who are actually running the country we
don't even know their names okay they're
just part of the blob they're just part
of the establishment they're just part
of the new ruling class and the new
social hierarchy that is taking power
more and more and more
and more
i'm so glad you like that clip i like
that clip too but a lot of people i'm
sorry to say are not getting
notifications for these clips if you
want to get notifications ring the bell
subscribe more importantly head on over
to apple podcast spotify stitcher google
play myspace xanga aol instant messenger
wherever you get your podcasts
subscribe to the michael knoll show
we'll see
[Music]
[Music]